das man sich auch jetzt mal deinen
Lodzett
Kada muryuu
Auch schon jemand von euch da. Oh tatsächlich
instant spawn hier im chat
Kurzer stream ja lange geht es heute nicht vielleicht gucken wir uns die zweite hälfte von dem konferenztalk an
Ich muss mal gucken ich bin auch ziemlich kaputt
Morgen tach homeoffice freitag muss ich noch mal nach frankfurt allerdings nur bis 14 uhr 30
All michael 50 billionen also das sollte man aushalten sollte irgendwie erträglich sein alles
Und
Etwas gibt es neues erzählt bei irgendwas gibt es irgendwas spannendes bei euch ansonsten
Ich habe für heute gar nichts mehr ausgedacht wie gesagt wir gucken vielleicht ein paar sachen
Gucken die konferenztalk weiter oder ich bin ja auch nur ein bisschen über eine stunde da
Dann muss ich bettke bettke time
Gabs überlegt hat gab es irgendwelche spannende news oder so
Es wird irgendwas gehackt worden hat wieder microsoft irgendwelches dummes zeug gemacht wo man sich denkt
Wie kommen die immer nur auf diese beknackten namen
Aber ich glaube da war nix oder war heute irgendwas war noch mal ganz ganz kurz im heise news ticker
Viele vertraut sabotage bei der bahn ich glaube die bahn die musst du gar nicht sabotieren die sabotieren sich schon genug selbst
Das war wahrscheinlich die bahn selbst weil sie sich gedacht haben fuck sonst müssen wir wieder zugeben dass bei uns nix funktioniert
Komm lass mal schnell das war schnell ein paar glasfaserkabel durchzwickeln
Mit dem knibbeck seitenschneider
Muss wenn schon der gute sein ich meine irgendwo müssen die millionen bei der bahn auch hin da kann man schon knibbeck seitenschneider holen
Muss man nicht mit so billig all die ding rum handwerken
Mein aldi
Also das nicht wirklich mein aldi aber ihr wisst was ich meine also den aldi hier in der nähe
Die haben jetzt ladesäulen für elektroautos
Ich glaube ich gehe demnächst da mal hin
Beim ica war ich schon
Ich weiß gar nicht ob es free ist oder ob man sich anmelden muss also bei ica ist es free ist aber glaub limitiert auf 60 minuten
Oder irgendwas war da ich kann mich nicht mehr richtig dran erinnern aber
Ich war tatsächlich im ikea drin es ist ja nicht so als
Hätte ich komplett
Free entertainment neighbors wi-fi gemacht
Die
Hug es aus habe morgen einen probe arbeitstag im zuge ich habe schon gelesen im zu würde ich dachte
Dacht dachten schon
im Zuge eines Rekrutierungsprozesses für eine Ausbildung als Fachinformal, ein
Rokkirekrutierungsprozess, mein Gott die denken alles, sie sind das nächste Google
mann, die haben immer immer Panik und mangels an Fachkräfte, aber ausbilden
will auch keiner. Egal, weiß ja nicht, gut anscheinend wollen sie ja ausbilden, sonst
hätten sie keinen Rekrutierungsprozess. Hast du irgendwelche
Tipps? Es kommt drauf an, was das für ein Termin ist. Also was kommt da auf dich zu?
Die müssen sich ja irgendwie ein bisschen geäußert haben. Ist das nur so vor
Selektion mit irgendwie ein bisschen Tests oder so oder ist das auch schon
mit irgendwelche Leuten die Ahnung haben oder ist das denn das nur
irgendwelche Personal-Tussis oder ja man auch das war jetzt war jetzt gemein
aber ja naja, sind das nur irgendwelche BWL Leute oder hast du auch wirklich dann
jemanden wo du vielleicht die Ausbildung machst schon da? Ist schwierig, weil bei
allen, du wirst eigentlich bei allen nicht mit irgendwie Vorkenntnisse
glänzen können, weil die haben alle keine Ahnung von, wenn das irgendwelche
Rekrutierungsdinger sind, irgendwelche Standard-Workflows, irgendwelche
Personal-Leute bringt dir irgendwie irgendwie erzählen was tolles gemacht
hast nichts, weil die können damit eh nichts anfangen. Da muss man sich dann
dementsprechend darauf einstellen. Sollte das allerdings was sein mit Leuten die
ein bisschen Plan von der Technik haben, dann ist das natürlich nicht verkehrt.
Ich weiß nicht, machen die irgendwelche Tests? Ich meine die müssen irgendwie gesagt haben, was
der Sache ist. Deutsche Bahn bevorzugt Prominente, aha. Da muss ich ein bisschen
größer noch auf YouTube werden, dass meine Züge auch bevorzugt werden.
Na ja gut, letztendlich ist das aber auch irgendwie klar, wenn sich da
irgendwie der sonst wie Oberboss von irgendwas ankündigt, dann wollen sie
immer einen guten Eindruck machen. Das ist bei uns auf der Arbeit ähnlich.
Ich sitze hier in der Nähe dort wo auch unser 24-7-Support sitzt, das ist
relativ großes Büro, da ist auch so eine große Monitoring Wand und so was, da
sitze ich in der Nähe, ich bekomme das mit. Manchmal kündigt sich irgendwie der
Chef an, also der Ober-Oberchef kündigt sich an. Meistens führt er dann
irgendwelche super krassen Millionen verdienenden Außendienstleute bei uns
rum, weil irgendwie muss man ja Geld bekommen und da ist das bei uns auch so.
Dann sagen die Leute so was in der Richtung wie, ja hier, mach mal schnell
alle Fehler von der Wand weg. Und dann denke ich immer so, die Wand ist dazu da
Fehler anzuzeigen, wenn man Fehler weg macht von der Wand, die bestehen, aber
dann, egal, mach mal Fehler weg, hier soll keiner rote Bilder sehen, hier soll keiner
rote Icons sehen auf der Wand. Und dann werden dann immer irgendwelche
Tabs aufgemacht mit Dashboards, wo überhaupt nichts drin ist, dass es nicht
so aussieht, als ist da irgendwas rot. Oh man, das ist alles mit mehr Schein als
sein immer.
Naja.
Schwachstelle, JavaScript, Sandbox, Bibliothek, MV2, hast du damals schon gehört?
Nein, sagt mir gar nichts. VM2.js. Advanced VM Sandbox für Node.js.
Was?
Ah, das ist, wenn man irgendwelche Sachen ausführt, die einem vom Frontend
untergeschoben werden können. Tja. Wenn JavaScript auf dem Backend macht, ist eh selber
dran schuld. Alter, warum ist mein KacW heute so ultra laut?
Wie schwer ist es bei Big-Tech-Unternehmen als Software-Entwickler
reinzukommen? Das kann man pauschal nicht sagen. Wie viel
Erfahrung hast du, was für Technologien kannst du, kannst du einen Binarridge
re-inverten? Das kann man pauschal nicht sagen, also manch einer würde sagen easy,
ich habe 50 Anfragen und alle wollen sie mich haben. Ein großer nach dem
anderen, also nach dem Motto, und ein anderer würde sagen, ich find nix.
Also, ja. Ach so, hier, sind mit den Ausbildern, 4-stündige Tests hab ich
schon gemacht. Ach so, Vorstellungsgespräche mit dem Ausbilder, okay,
das ist natürlich was anderes. Das ist was anderes. Dann hast du den
eklichen Kram schon hinter dir und du kommst in die nähere Auswahl,
beziehungsweise wahrscheinlich in die engere, die werden ja jetzt nicht 30
Leute einladen oder so für. Tja, hab ich da irgendwelche Tipps? Also, ist jetzt nicht so
als hätte ich mega viele Vorstellungsgespräche gemacht in meinem
Leben, ja. Hat meistens eigentlich immer mehr oder weniger schnell geklappt bei
mir. Aber eine Sache kann ich mich an meine Ausbildung, hab ich glaube ich schon ein
paar mal erzählt, in meiner Ausbildung dran erinnern, also was sich im
Nachhinein alles ganz gut rausgestellt hat, war, als ich damals, also für den
Ausbildungsplatz als Fachinformatiker Systemintegrations irgendwie vor 15
Jahren, da hab ich auch einen Test vorher gemacht und danach bin ich quasi ins
Vorstellungsgespräch rein, beziehungsweise wurde gefragt im Flur, wer
will denn anfangen. Ich dachte mir, ich muss mal bald zum Zug, ich fang mal an.
Zumindest als ich dann da reingegangen bin, hatte ich so spontan irgendwie das
Bedürfnis zu sagen, dass ja manche Sachen irgendwie gemein waren in dem
Einstellungstest. Das ist vielleicht, ich sag nicht, dass das irgendwie der
ultimative Satz ist, den du sagen solltest. Nee, nee, auf gar nichts, sag den nicht. Ich meine nur, was mir
danach aufgefallen ist, dadurch konnte ich unbewusst, das habe ich nicht
absichtlich gemacht, dadurch konnte ich unbewusst ein bisschen steuern, was die
jetzt sagen, weil wenn man sich nebeneinander, also nicht nebeneinander, wenn man sich
voreinander setzt, ja du sagst nichts, der sagt nichts, dann ist der natürlich im
Zugzwang irgendwas zu sagen. Ich meine jetzt nicht, dass du den voll labern sollst,
so nach dem Motto, alter hier ich bin da, ich bin der geilste. Nee, aber so hat man zumindest
die Chance, so ein bisschen zu beeinflussen, was drankommt. Ja, vielleicht
findest du irgendein, vielleicht findest du irgendein Thema, was man mal so neben, ja nach
der Begrüßung so im Nebensatz sagen kann, worauf er dann einsteigen kann.
Ansonsten haben die halt schon, wenn es ein größerer Laden ist, irgendwelche
Vorgehensworkflows, wie was ja, was da in den Gesprächen geführt wird.
Zumindest dich anschweigen ist immer doof, weil dann wirst du im Zweifelsfall
zu euch gefragt, was du eigentlich nicht gefragt werden willst.
Sag ihm, du benutzt Arch, by the way, das ist ein guter Tipp.
Nee, ich habe auch noch nichts bestellt, weder CPU noch GPU, aber ich
habe es mir immer noch vorgenommen. Dezember ist es soweit, Leute. Ich warte
jetzt mal, was Intel noch vorstellt. Dezember gibt es neuen Rechner.
Schenker Laptops, keine Ahnung. Also ich fand mal vor Jahren diese XMG, genau
hier, XMG Dinger, ziemlich nice. Ich hatte die mal sogar vor zig Jahren
hatte ich oder wollte ich, ich weiß es gar nicht mehr. Irgendwas wegen Sponsoring
mal gesprochen. Hat sich aber nichts ergeben und außerdem habe ich keine
Laptops mehr. Also ich habe kein Laptop, also ich brauche auch kein Laptop.
Ich kann da nichts zu sagen. Weiß ich echt nicht, was man da drauf achten muss
bei Laptops. Ich meine, klar, die üblichen Geschichten, Tastatur, Bildschirm,
Batterielaufzeit oder abziehungsweise Akku-Laufzeit, das weiß ich ja selbst.
Ansonsten wüsste ich es nicht.
Du sollst einen Taschenrechner mitnehmen zum Vorstellungsgespräch.
Oh nee. Moment, als was machst du deine Ausbildung? Als Anwendungsentwickler
wollen die von dir, dass du irgendwelche bescheuerten Übungsaufgaben an der
Tafel löst oder was? Boah, da hätte ich jetzt keinen Bock drauf.
Musst schon seinen Grund haben, warum ich einen Taschenrechner mitnehmen soll.
Abschlussprüfungstipp, ja, den ultimativen Tipp für die Abschlussprüfung
und eigentlich auch so ziemlich den einzigen Tipp für die Abschlussprüfung,
den man braucht. Mach alte Abschlussprüfungen. Scheiß auf die Vorbereitung in der Schule,
scheiß auf die Vorbereitung in der A- also, was ich meine ist, denk nicht,
dass nur weil du gut in der Berufsschule warst, du automatisch gute Prüfungen schreibst,
weil du Plan hast von dem, was in Betrieb gemacht wird, dass du automatisch gute
Prüfungen schreibst, weil die IHK-Prüfungen haben nichts mit der Realität zu tun.
Du musst die Art und Weise verstehen, wie die IHK Fragen stellt und auf IHK-Weise
Antworten lernen. Das brauchst du nicht im späteren Leben, es nützt dir nichts dazu,
was du im Betrieb gelernt hast, es nützt dir nichts dazu, was du in der Berufsschule
gelernt hast und du kannst es quasi nachdem du die Prüfung verstanden hast,
auch wieder vergessen. Du wirst es in deinem Leben nie wieder brauchen, bis du stirbst.
Was hoffentlich noch ein bisschen hin ist. Du musst alte Prüfungen machen,
das ist das Einzige, was hilft. Und was meint ihr, Chet? Jemand, der drei Jahre
eine Ausbildung gemacht hat und richtig gut ist in dem, was er macht und auch super Noten
in der Berufsschule hat, aber sich keine alten Prüfungen angeguckt hat versus jemand,
versus jemand, der den Beruf überhaupt nicht gelernt hat, der nie eine Ausbildung,
der nie diese Ausbildung gemacht hat, sich allerdings zwei Monate lang auf die Abschlussprüfung
vorbereitet, ohne je damit was gemacht zu haben. Was meint ihr, wer die bessere Prüfung schreibt?
Also ich tippe auf den, der die Abschlussprüfung gelernt hat, weil es geht in der Abschlussprüfung
nicht wirklich um Fachwissen beziehungsweise um Ahnung haben, es geht einfach um IHK Fragen
verstehen und IHK Antworten liefern. Also du musst Abschlussprüfung machen. Wenn du
Abschlussprüfung machst, du kannst dir in der Abschlussprüfung auch die alten Antworten
angucken und dann siehst du relativ schnell, ob das jetzt gecheckt hast oder nicht. Die
haben immer wieder diese, die haben immer wieder ähnliche Fragenstellungen. Sie sind
Auszubildende in der Alligator GmbH oder irgendwie sowas, fängt es dann meistens an. Ihr Kollege
fragt sie zu der Einrichtung eines neuen Desktop-Arbeitsplatzes. Wie gehen sie im Beratungsgespräch vor?
Und irgendwie sowas kommt an. Ordnen sie die Begriffe zu. Tastatur, USB-Stick, Maus,
Toilettenpapier, Smartphone. Und dann musst du dann irgendwie was einordnen. Das ist immer
der gleiche Blödsinn. Also du musst auf jeden Fall Abschlussprüfung machen, anders geht
es nicht. Wir gucken das Video nach. Ja, wir gucken das gleich weiter. Wann kommt ein neuer
PC bei mir in Frage? Wie gesagt, Ende des Jahres. Ende des Jahres kaufe ich einen. Richtig
fette Kiste. Wir haben es letztens ausgerechnet. Wird wahrscheinlich um die 4500 Euro kosten.
Easy Money, Easy Life, Any Primers. Ich wusste gar nicht, ob ihr wusstet, dass man, wenn
man Amazon Prime Account hat, den man mit Twitch verknüpft hat, kostenlos einen Streamer,
den man gerne guckt und subscriben kann. Kostet euch nichts. Außer Amazon Prime. Man sagt
es immer so. Ach, das ist doch alles kostenlos. Stimmt ja gar nicht. Man braucht ja Amazon
Prime für. Aber wenn man Amazon Prime hat, kann man einen Streamer seiner Wahl unterstützen.
Zum Beispiel mich, dass ich mir im Dezember einen 4500 Euro Rechner kaufen kann. Den
kaufe ich mir auch so. Aber dann geht es nicht so sehr in die Kohle. Big Stonks Time.
Ich kann keine Sellouts. Ist mir auch egal. Ihr müsst mich nicht subscriben. Du hattest
nur ein Gespräch eingestellt. Ja, war bei mir bei der Ausbildung genauso. Habe ich ja
schon erzählt. Das war das mit dem Typ, der sich quasi komplett eingeschwitzt. Das war
ein richtiger Schwitzer, Alter, beim Vorstellungsgespräch. Also nicht nicht nicht nicht in der Chef,
sondern ein anderer Typ, der auch Vorstellungsgespräche am gleichen Tag hatte. Ich habe glaube ich
in meinem Leben noch nie jemand gesehen, der so krass nervös war. Ich glaube, ich habe
wirklich, ich habe noch nie so einen nervösen Menschen gesehen. Ich war mit drei, nee, mit
zwei anderen habe ich im Gang gesessen zum Vorstellungsgespräch da an dem Tag. Mit irgendeinem
Mädel, die hat die Ausbildung bekommen später, allerdings nicht in Frankfurt, sondern an
einem anderen Standort und mit so einem Anzugtyp. Und da hat wahrscheinlich Anzug angehabt,
weil sein Vater ihm gesagt hat, zieh einen Anzug an. Alter, der Typ, der war so ultra
nervös. Der hat gezittert und geschwitzt. Der war, der war richtig fertig. Der war richtig
fertig. Und als ich dann rausgekommen bin, ich bin da zuerst ins Vorstellungsgespräch
gegangen, weil ich mir gedacht habe, ich muss mal schnell wieder zum Zug, also zur Bahn zurück
fahren. Ich bin da zuerst, ich bin da der erste, der ins Vorstellungsgespräch gegangen
ist. Und als ich dann rausgekommen bin, da hat der Typ mich so angeguckt, so nach dem
Motto, und wie ist es gelaufen, wie ist es gelaufen. Und da habe ich so, so aus Spaß
zu ihm eigentlich gesagt. Habe ich zu ihm gemeint, so, boah, Alter, was die alles wissen
wollen. Das war eigentlich eher Joke. Ey, der Typ ist, der Typ ist fast ohnmächtig geworden.
Der war eh schon, das war keine Absicht, Leute. Ohne Scheiß. Das war keine Absicht. Der war
richtig fertig, Alter. Ich habe den auch nie wieder gesehen. Keine Ahnung, also er scheint
die Stelle ja nicht gekriegt zu haben. Ich habe mir da gar nichts, ich habe mir da gar
nichts bei gedacht. Es war halt einfach so eine spontane blöde Antwort, ja. Der war
richtig fertig, Alter. Ich weiß nicht, was aus dem geworden ist. Ich weiß ja nicht,
wie er heißt. Ich weiß nicht, was er dann gemacht hat. Er hat zumindest die Ausbildung
anscheinend nicht gekriegt. Obatzdr, Dankeschön. Massive Subscriptions hier. Hast du was mit
der Switch Pro mitbekommen? Nö. Switch Pro wird dann einfach neue Hardware sein, oder?
Also muss ja. Und dann ist Frage, wie es mit Abwärtskompatibilität aussieht. Vielleicht
wird das ein bisschen Richtung Gamecube und Wii von der Hardware. Das war ja im Prinzip
das Gleiche. Bis zur Wii U war das eigentlich mehr oder weniger die gleiche Technik. Bloß
nur halt schneller. Ich halte von Zwischen-Konsolen-Releases nichts. Wenn es ein neues Konsolenrelease ist,
okay, man, die Switch ist ja auch schon busy her jetzt. 2017 ist auch schon 5 Jahre alt.
Können durchaus mal wieder was rausbringen. Ich meine, es gab 3 Games auf der Switch,
die sich gelohnt haben zu kaufen. Der Rest ist eigentlich jetzt die Konsole komplett
von der Arsch gewesen. Wobei, das stimmt nicht. Das stimmt nicht. Es gab durchaus. Es gab
vielleicht 5 Games. Die Donkey Kong-Teile waren gut. Mario Odyssey war gut. Splatoon,
wenn man drauf steht, meinetwegen. Ich mochte ja persönlich, Splatoon war nicht meins.
Link's Awakening Remake fand ich auch sehr niedlich, auch wenn es übelste Frame-Probleme
hatte. Es gab schon, sag mal so, aber unter 10 Games, für die sich die Switch lohnt.
Also, weiß nicht, ich hab's mir komplett umsonst gekauft eigentlich, das Teil. Ich
hab relativ viel Breath of the Wild gespielt, Mario Odyssey, das Link's Awakening Remake,
aber ansonsten hält sich wirklich sehr in Grenzen. Ja, es könnte durchaus mal eine neue
Konsolengeneration geben. Dass das Ding, also ich habe nichts davon mitbekommen, keine Ahnung,
dass das Ding DLSS hat, das kann ich mir tatsächlich vorstellen, weil das ist ja ein komplettes
Nvidia-Teil, die Switch. Und, ja, warum nicht? Also der Shield TV beispielsweise und die
Switch sind so unterschiedlich nicht, was Hardware angeht. Die Switch ist im Prinzip
so eine Nvidia-Box, Nvidia-Android-TV-Box, nur ohne Android. Eigentlich wär's gar nicht
so blöd gewesen, wenn Nintendo das auf Android-Basis gemacht hätte, zumindest optional die Möglichkeit
gehabt hätte, in irgendein Android-System zu booten oder sowas, weil dann hättest du
zumindest ein paar Games gehabt, die du spielen kannst, nicht nur fünf Stück. Gibt nix Neues.
Ja, gibt, ja gut, was heißt das? Wie gesagt, mitgekriegt hab ich auch nix, aber es gibt
ja schon seit Jahren Gerüchte. Kann man doch flashen, wusste ich nicht, aber wundert mich
nicht. Wie gesagt, Shield TV und die Switch sind von dem Chip, also von der Kiste. Kein
großer Unterschied. Ich sag immer, wenn ich keinen Plan hab. Ich sag manchmal auch, wenn
ich keinen Bock hab zu Sachen, wo ich mich auskenn, dass ich keinen Plan hab, aber in
dem Fall auch wirklich keinen Plan. Authentisch bleiben und Freundlichkeit ist immer gut.
Ja, Freundlichkeit geb ich dir recht, authentisch würd ich dir im Prinzip auch recht geben,
aber manche Sachen solltest du halt nicht sagen, auch wenn du's normalerweise so sagen
würdest. Na, wenn authentisch für dich ist, Digger, mach Auge, dann solltest du das vielleicht
nicht sagen. Max, du nutzt doch VMWR. Funktioniert, Shared, Clipboard und so weiter. Nein, ähm,
nee, nee, nee. Nee, nee, nee, funktioniert. Ich hab es erst letztens ausprobiert, kannst
dich vergessen. Geht nicht. Deswegen ist Wayland auch der letzte Crap für virtualisiertes
Linux. Weißt du, was das beste war? Wayland hat in VMWR noch nicht mal FPS gehabt. Also
hatte 0 FPS, kein Screen Refresh. Du musstest von Hand den Screen Refreshen. Also du musstest
quasi das Fenster resizen, erst dann hat er das Screen Refreshed. Richtig kaputt. Dann
musstest du dann irgendeine Environment Variable setzen, dass es trotzdem ging. Ja, nächstes
Jahr wird das Jahr des Linux Desktops, ich sag's euch. Ja, wie gesagt, Physi Abschlussprüfung
oder Fachinformatik Abschlussprüfung, genau das gleiche Kram. Ja, so sieht's aus. Dummschwärzer
gegen Fachkompetenz gewinnt. Nee, Dummschwärzer allein bringt dir nicht allzu viel für die
schriftliche Prüfung. Oder, Moment, oder meintest du die mündliche Abschlussprüfung
oben? Vorhand. Wer auch immer das war. Äh, wer war denn das vorhand? Meintest du die
mündliche Abschlussprüfung oder die schriftliche? Ich dachte du willst die schriftliche machen.
Bei der mündlichen sieht das anders aus. Also bei der mündlichen solltest du zumindest
schon Ahnung haben, was du da gemacht hast im Projekt. In der Suppe. Ja, bestes Leaked
Foto. Dankeschön für den Sub. Stripes Massive Sub. 39 Monate, überlegt euch mal, wie lang
das schon ist. Das sind ja schon über drei Jahre. Graser Scheiß. Ich auch nicht. Ich
weiß nicht, ob ihr das wusstet, aber ich war auch noch nicht in einer Wüste. Leute,
es entscheidet sich morgen, ob ich Mobile Tracks Games Sellout mache. Okay, sollte ich
vielleicht so nicht sagen. Wenn das dann jemand hört, dann macht die kein Sellout mit mir.
Wobei, ist mir auch egal. Ist halt Tracks Mobile Game. Ich werde es dann genauso überzeugend
vortragen wie das Genshin Impact Sponsoring. Wobei ich denke, dass Genshin Impact an sich
gar kein schlechtes Game ist. Genshin Impact auf ApoRed Star. Moment, das muss ich mir
jetzt angucken. Genshin Impact ApoRed. Zeigt mal. Wo ist das? Okay. Wo ist das Sponsoring
Genshin Impact von ApoRed? Es muss doch irgendwo geben. Oder hat er das Video gelöscht? Das
will ich jetzt sehen. Hat er gelöscht? Ist es das hier? Ist es das hier? Jawoll. Jawoll.
Das muss ich mir angucken. Auf trocken am Start ist er. Moment, das muss ich mir kurz
angucken.
Das ist doch vollkommen in Ordnung. Ist doch genauso mies wie meins. Brutal schön, naja.
Das ist so geil. Das ist genau der gleiche Shit, den sie mir geschrieben haben, was man
sagen soll. Null. Na gut, war wahrscheinlich die gleiche Agentur. Ach, Moment, das ist,
das gibt es auch ungeschnitten? Ich dachte, das ist alles. Ich dachte, das ist alles.
Ich meine, für wie viel haben die da bezahlt? Okay, ungeschnitten. Leute, ich muss das
jetzt sehen. Ich muss das jetzt sehen. Wo ist das? ApoRed ist, nee. Plamiert sich mit,
was ist das für ein Video? Okay. Was für ein Video? Neues Mimivideo. Ich bin im deutschen
YouTube-Game nicht, ich kenne die alle nicht. ApoRed kenne ich noch aus Call of Duty Zeiten.
Das da? Der Typ? Also, aber Leon getroffen habe ich mir ziemlich wurscht. Meine Entschuldigung
an ApoRed. Oh, come on. Was ist denn da schon wieder los? Okay, wohin muss ich? 1522. Okay.
In einem Spiel steckt, und wie gut er sich auskennt. Auf geht's. Auch trocken am Start.
Dieses heutige Video wird gesponsert von Genshin Impact, Freunde. Du liest es doch noch ab.
Zu geil. Ist doch super. Woher hat er denn die angekattete Variante?
Ganz ehrlich? Ich finde es gar nicht. Ach, vom Cutter. Okay, ganz ehrlich, mit dem Cutter
würde ich nicht mehr zusammenarbeiten, wenn der mein Material einfach an irgendwelche
Leute schickt. Unabhängig davon, ob das jetzt funny ist oder nicht, aber das gehört sich
nicht. Meint ja ApoRed, war doch schon mal in einer Wüste. Leute, ich habe mir übelst
einen abgebrochen. Also, bevor wir das jetzt weiter gucken. Wir gucken gleich den Talk
fertig, ja? Bevor wir das weiter gucken, Sekunde. Nur mal so, nur mal so. Also, nur mal zum
Vergleich mein Genshin Impact-Sponsoring, ja? Das ist auch nicht besser. Pass mal auf.
So, wer es nicht gesehen hat, mein Genshin Impact-Sponsoring. Jetzt, obacht.
Das bringt mich auch zum Partner des heutigen Videos. Genshin Impact ist ein Open-World-Adventure-Game
mit einer großen Anzahl verschiedener Charaktere im Anime-Style. Genshin Impact ist für PS5,
PS4, PC, auch für Mobilgeräte, iOS und Android erhältlich. Die große atmosphärische offene
Welt ist ein Gieber zu erforschen. Oh Gott, das ist so schlecht. Eine Welt voller Geheimnisse
in der 7-Region, 7 Göttern. Wie könnte das anders sein? Auch 7 Elemente gibt, die kombiniert
werden können, um neue Synergien zu schaffen und noch mehr coole Angriffe auszuführen.
Die geschlossene Karte von Genshin, wenn man nur Monstadt, Lyos und Mero mitzählt, ist
mehr als 5.900 Fußballfelder in der realen Welt. Das Spiel hat regelmäßig Inhaltsupdates
für den kürzlich veröffentlichten Patch 3.1, der neue aufregende Region wie Sumero
mit einem neuen Wüstengebiet bringt. Ich war noch nie in einer Wüste, aber ich kann
die geheimnisvolle Wüste, die alten Ruinen in Sumero ergänzen. Ich muss mich immer wegpissen,
durch diesen Pate, Alter. Ich war noch nie in einer Wüste. Zu geil. Ich war noch nie
in einer Wüste, aber ich kann die geheimnisvolle Wüste, die alten Ruinen in Sumero erkunden.
Und es gibt drei neue Helden im Spiel. Sino, ein 5-Sterne Electro, Kanans, ein 4-Sterne
Hydro, beide recht mächtig und schließlich Nilo, ein 5-Sterne Hydro, recht mächtig mit
einem Schwert. Zusätzlich zu den liebevoll gestalteten Anime-Visuals bietet jeder Charakter
seine eigene spannende Hintergrundgeschichte und ermöglicht tiefgreifende Interaktion
mit der Spielwelt. Zur Feier des Updates auf Version 3.1 zeigt Genshin Impact die Geschichte
der Spieler in Genshin in Offline-Werbung auf der ganzen Welt. In Deutschland werden
die Erinnerungsspieler in der Münchner Hauptbahnhof gezeigt. Der Rest ist jetzt langweilig. Ich
war doch nie in einer Wüste, Alter. Darfst du sagen, wie viele du dafür bekommen hast?
Ähm... Moment, ich muss mal kurz gucken, wo ich hier gewesen bin gerade. Keine Ahnung.
Darf man fragen, wie viele du dafür bekommen hast? Bestimmt weniger als ApoRed. Geh ich
mal von aus. Ich dürfte es wahrscheinlich sagen. Ich glaube, ich habe nichts unterschrieben,
dass ich nichts sagen dürfte. Nicht sagen darf. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich sagen soll.
Ja, 4-stellig ist das. Das kann ich sagen. Also im Ernst, 90 Sekunden, übelst krassesten
Sellout of Doom mache ich nicht unter 4-stellig. Und jetzt könnt ihr mal überlegen, wenn ich
das in der Richtung schon nicht unter 4-stellig mache, was ApoRed gekriegt hat. Guck mal,
jetzt... Okay. Richtig coole Charaktere. Ob es jetzt ein Katzenmädchen ist, ein Fuchsmädchen
oder ein Samurai. Eine richtig geile Option. Gibt es da einen Samurai? Ja, ich glaube,
es gibt den ganzen Game einfach noch mal viel mehr Atmosphäre. Ah ja, gut. Alter, wo ist
das Problem? Wo ist das Problem? Ganz ehrlich, der ließ den Krempel halt vor, hat keinen
Plan davon. Ich habe auch keinen Plan davon gehabt, Mann. Wo ist das Problem? Außer ich
finde es wirklich nicht okay, ich meine, ich kenne das Video da vorn danach nicht, aber
ich finde es wirklich nicht okay, dass ein ungeschnittenes Material, das nicht gedacht
ist zum veröffentlichen, irgendwo liegt. Dass er sagt, dass er das Game fühlt. Okay,
das habe ich tatsächlich nicht gesagt. Man hat mir aber angehört, wie sehr ich das Game
fühle, oder? Hi IQ Time. Postchamp? Die haben unterschiedliche Kulturen, die haben einfach
einen unterschiedlichen Vibe. Das heißt, ihr habt mega viel Abwechslung. Okay, ich finde
es insofern, wenn man es verkauft, als ich persönlich empfehle euch das, das ist blöd,
aber ansonsten ist doch kein Unterschied zu Fernsehwerbung. Wie lang geht denn das? Es
ist gleich fertig, okay. Also muss man trotzdem sagen, Hut ab an den Cutter, dass der da draus
was gemacht hat. Ich meine, was willst du da draus schneiden? Wie willst du da draus
ein Wärmespot schneiden? Also mein. Geht das noch weiter? Wie, das war es jetzt oder
wie? Moment, das geht das ganze Video über jetzt doch, oder wie? Kritische Hase. Ja,
hat frei gesprochen, würde ich sagen. Ja gut, aber mein, wo ist das Problem jetzt? Ich finde
es immer ein bisschen blöd, wenn man die Sachen so verkauft, quasi so nach dem Motto, es liegt
mir am Herzen. Ich empfehle, ich persönlich empfehle euch das, aber das hätte ich jetzt
in das Video nicht rein interpretiert. Don Cuyon, Dankeschön für den Sub. Ne, Raid Shadow
Legends, die könne ich mal, das mache ich nicht. Ich mache mobile Crab Werbung demnächst
vielleicht, seit denn die hören, dass ich sage, ich mache mobile Crab Werbung, wollen
da nicht mal. NordVPN war auch wieder am Start, NordVPN erinnert sich dann immer wieder, aber
daran, wenn sie mit mir ein Video machen wollen, dass ich dieses Video gemacht habe, wo unter
dem NordVPN auf dem Bild ist, das ist immer geil. NordVPN, irgendein random NordVPN Dude
schreibt eine Anfrage, ich sage, jo klar, machen wir NordVPN Sponsoring und dann fällt
ihnen immer wieder ein, ach ne, du bist ja der Kerl mit diesem Anti-VPN Video, ne ne,
dann wollen wir doch nicht. Das ist auch geil, wobei ich denke, so langsam müssten Stomach
gelernt haben. Leute, wo wir gerade beim Thema NordVPN sind, für alle, die es nicht gesehen
haben, VfB Stuttgart, beste Cyber Abwehr für VfB Fans. Das ist kein Fake Tweet, das ist
wirklich so. Wenn der VfB Stuttgart schon Werbung von NordVPN macht, dann sollte man
sich aber YouTuber nicht so drüber aufregen. Achso. Ja, wir kommen jetzt den Talk gleich
weiter. Noch fertig gucken, ob das was wird heute.
Okay, Leute, falls ihr irgendwas übersehen habt, schreibt es doch mal in den Chat, ich
glaube nicht. Wir gucken jetzt den restlichen Konferenztalk von gestern. Wir haben gestern
angefangen, einen Konferenztalk zu gucken von der NDC Sydney. Da stehen sie alle auf
dem Kopf. Oh, cringe-Joke, ich weiß. Und da ging es um die Geschichte, so ein bisschen
die Geschichte des Internets und vor allem, was ich da dran ganz gut fand, so ein bisschen
historisch die Web-Frameworks und Entwicklung von Browser und JavaScript, CSS und solche
Geschichten. Wir sind stehen geblieben, glaube ich, als es um Ruby on Rails ging. Ruby. Ob
hier sind wir stehen geblieben? Wir gucken uns einfach die letzte Minute noch mal an.
Da geht es nämlich um Webforms und Webforms ist so ziemlich das Schrecklichste, was es
je gegeben hat. Dort genug. Böse Zungen würden behaupten,
es ist immer noch Müll. Leute, das ist mal Content hier, oder? Von
ApoRed zu einem HiIQ-Konferenztalk. Danach noch mal ein Excel-E-Sports. Was heißt Content?
Es ist mein Reaction-Content, ja? Ist ja nicht so, als hätte ich da irgendwie einen Handschlag
für gemacht für den Content. Und wisst ihr, dass wir diesem Editor jahrzehntelange Anzeigen
zu verdanken haben im Internet, wo dann da steht, diese Seite ist optimiert für den Microsoft
Internet Explorer 800 x 600? Genau wegen diesem Mist, weil es absolut positionierte Elemente
in der Webseite sind. Wenn ich das schon sehe, kriege ich wieder Anfälle. Excel-E-Sport.
Ja, haben wir gestern schon geguckt. Ich war überrascht, dass es Excel-E-Sport gibt.
Ja, Preserif, das habe ich gehört. Ich bin mir aber nicht sicher, ob es wirklich kommt
oder ob das angedacht ist. Das habe ich auch schon gelesen. Und ich bin mir gar nicht
sicher, in welchem Kontext ich das letztens gelesen habe. Es ging darum, dass man sich
erhofft, dass eben als SAS-Features weiter Einzug in CSS erhalten. Ich weiß nicht, ob
das nur ein Proposal ist oder wirklich dann kommen soll. Ja. Silverlight, oh je. Leute,
Silverlight an sich war gar nicht so doof im Kontext zu der Zeit, wo Flash angesagt
war. Aber Silverlight kam mal raus. Ein paar haben Silverlight verwendet. Dann hat Apple
Flash mehr oder weniger abgesägt und auch nichts anderes unterstützt. Aber Silverlight
war wieder tot. Ich weiß nicht, wie lange Silverlight gelebt hat. Eins, zwei Jahre
oder so nicht lang.
Das ist wahrscheinlich in der Mitte, oder? Dann schalte ich das, gehe zurück in meinen
Browser, reloade. Und da geht's los. Ich kann nach Hause gehen. Das ist toll. Das funktioniert
nur, wenn man die absoluten Pixel-Positionen auf der Seite legen kann. Und diese Idee
begann ein paar Jahre später zu fallen. Also der hottest way in 2002 war eigentlich
ziemlicher Müll. Switchen mit Java-UI. Ich kenne auch Remote-Management-Interfaces mit
Java-UI. Rails, Ruby. Ich bin ein riesen Fan, was Ruby angeht, die Programmiersprache.
Ich mag Ruby. Leider ist Rails total in der Versenkung verschwunden und es benutzt keiner
mehr. Dementsprechend ist Ruby an sich auch nicht super beliebt. Wenn man mal zehn Jahre
zurückguckt, vor zehn Jahren war Ruby auch schon auslaufend. Aber da gab es massig Zeug
und ganz viele Ideen sind entstanden im Ruby-Umfeld. Wer mal Express.js-Seite gemacht hat in Node.js,
das ist eindeutig von Ruby-Frameworks inspiriert. Das merkste. Und Rails war das Ding, wo die
Leute gesagt haben, wir sind jetzt Rockstar-Web-Entwickler. Ruby. Rails war wirklich nice. Man darf nicht
vergessen, bis dahin haben die Leute Webforms gemacht und jetzt gibt es Ruby on Rails. Ruby
on Rails ist in diesem ganzen Vortrag das erste moderne Web-Framework, so wie die heute noch
funktionieren. Wo man zumindest die Struktur wieder erkennt. Ruby on Rails hatte integriert
Datenbank-Mikrations, Datenbank-Mapper, Views, Controller, Datenbank-Models, Task-Runner,
also alles das, was man heute von den meisten Frameworks kennt, kommt irgendwie aus der
Ruby-Zeit, also aus der Rails-Zeit. Und übrigens der Typ, der Erfinder von Ruby on Rails, also
dieser David Heinemeyer-Hansen, der ist Rennfahrer mittlerweile. Der fährt irgendwelche, irgendwelche
Rallies, hat wahrscheinlich genug Kohle verdient, aber, ja, Moncrustier macht er jetzt.
Ruby on Rails-Benutzer waren ziemlich viele Hipster-Programmer dabei. Twitter war übrigens
auch mal Rails. Ruby.
Rails war nice. Rails ist nice. Rails ist immer noch aktiv, also GitHub, Ruby on Rails, es
ist jetzt nicht so als wäre das dead oder so. Die Verbreitung ist halt ziemlich zurückgegangen,
aber es gibt immer noch viele, guck mal hier, 1500 Sterne, es gibt immer noch viele Ruby
on Rails-Anwendungen, die maintained werden müssen, und Rails hat vor 5 Stunden den letzten
Pull-Request bekommen, also so ist es ja nett. GitHub ist immer noch Rails, ziemlich sicher,
ja.
Die Leute hatten Tumblr-Blocks, Gatschi-Buzz.
Jetzt aber kein Rails-Tutorial, das letzte restliche Video, oder? Ne, ne, ne, sieht nicht
so aus, Rails ist in zwei Minuten wieder durch.
Webbrick, ja, stimmt, so ist das.
Das war auch super easy, wenn man das mal mit anderen Sachen vergleicht. In PAP haben
die Leute Handcrafted SQL noch schreiben müssen.
In Rails musstest du das nicht.
Übrigens, man muss sagen, ich finde immer noch Ruby ist eine super hübsche Programmiersprache.
Die Einrückungen sind übrigens keine Pflicht, im Vergleich zu peißen, ja, also das macht
man, weil es schick ist, aber man muss es nicht machen.
Das war auch relativ neu in Rails, dass da so ein Kommandozeilen-Tool dabei hat, wo du
Sachen anlegen konntest, ohne dass du den ganzen Boilerplate da immer von Hand basteln
musstest.
Viele Leute haben vor Ruby nie was von Testing gehört, also viele haben damit... AirSpec,
kennt jemand AirSpec? Quasi jedes halbwegs moderne Testing-Framework ist AirSpec, nur
für eine andere Sprache.
Schöne SQL-Injection zeige ich wieder gleich.
Ich glaube, man kann es nicht genug unterstreichen.
Rails war das erste wirklich moderne Web-Framework, wenn man mal von der heutigen Zeit guckt.
Alles andere davor war irgendwelcher Frickelshit.
Rails war wirklich das erste, was so quasi die Art und Weise, auch wenn man sich mal
die Ordner-Struktur anguckt, das hat da schon entscheidend mitgeprägt, wie das heute alles
aussieht.
Das sieht mehr oder weniger heute noch so aus, überall, egal wo ihr hinguckt, sei es
als Weltkit-Anwendung oder eine ASP.NET-Anwendung, das sieht zählig aus.
Ruby ist eine super Sprache, leider hat halt Ruby, außer dass es eine leise Sprache ist,
und Rails hat Ruby quasi mitgecarried jahrelang, auch in der Beliebtheit her.
Ganz viele anderen Libraries und Sachen sind entstanden, weil es eben Rails und das Ruby-Ökosystem
gab.
Allerdings Ruby an sich, ich weiß nicht warum, aber Ruby hat nie so diesen riesen Durchbruch
gehabt als Sprache an sich, und gerade mit dem Abflachen von Rails, wenn ihr mich fragt,
Ruby oder Python?
Ich finde Ruby ist die deutlich schönere Sprache.
Python ist auch okay, ist Ruby nicht saulangsam?
Ruby ist zumindest schneller als Python, und das hält es ja auch nicht davon ab, benutzt
zu werden.
Nicht viel, aber ist schneller.
Ruby, Web 2.0!
Ich glaube die JavaScript wurde etwa 2005 bis 2008 erneut geboren.
Und eine der Dinge, die das erneut erneut erneut erneut erneut erneut erneut erneut, war das Web 2.0-Wave und die Konkurrenz darin.
So, Web 2.0 war, als die Firmen realisierten, dass sie viel Kommerzwert von genieriertem Content erzielen können.
Und wenn du ein User bist, welche Sites werden du dir Zeit verbringen, Content zu generieren?
Das sind wahrscheinlich die, die für dich Spaß machen.
Oh, ich muss mein Laptop anklicken.
Das sind wahrscheinlich die, die einen schönen Interfacesystem haben.
Also, es war viel Druck auf die Entwickler, die die besten Interfacesystemen erzeugen.
So, dass die Entwickler ihre Zeit verbringen würden, um in diesen Bereichen zu arbeiten.
Einige der besten Arbeiten in diesen Bereichen wurden von Google erzeugt.
Das, was ich als neuer Entwickler von damals erinnere, war Google Maps.
Das stimmt, Google Maps hat schon mehrfach mindblown, also am Anfang die pure Existenz von Google Maps, dann Street View, was ja jeder für unmöglich gehalten hat, aber Google konnte das halt mit ihrem massig Geld machen.
Dann haben sie diese 3D-Ansicht mittlerweile, also Google Maps hat schon mehrfach gezeigt, was mit dem Browser möglich ist.
Nö, habe ich nicht gesehen auf Netflix.
Ajax.
AJAX.
XML.
Ja, das stimmt.
Aber gut, 2006 war das halt richtig geiler Shit.
Ich meine, damals war es das Beste, was man verwenden konnte, ernsthaft.
Es gab ja auch dann so ein paar Nachahmer von jQuery, so minimal jQuery, die angeblich dann besser, schneller und kleiner sein wollten.
Ich hab vergessen, was es da alles gab.
Irgendwas mit Z gab es da.
Erinnert sich noch einer an diese JavaScript?
Irgendwie was mit...
JavaScript?
Wie ist das?
Zepto oder sowas?
So minimal jQuery, nicht JavaScript, was laber ich denn?
Zepto?
Ja, jQuery.
Ist es Zepto, oder?
Ja, tatsächlich.
Zepto.
Jetzt haben die coolen Leute gesagt, jQuery ist plottet, Zepto ist nice.
Krass, oder?
Das wird kein Framework wieder schaffen.
Je wieder.
70% auf der top besuchten Seiten belammt jQuery benutzt.
70.
Das kriegt kein Vue.js, kein Svelte, kein Angular, kein React hin.
React vielleicht noch am ehesten.
Aber bestimmt auch nicht in den Regionen.
Firebug, beste.
Beste.
Der Typ, der Firebug-Entwickler ist, glaube ich, dann von Google eingekauft worden für Chrome,
wenn ich es noch richtig im Erinnerung habe.
Firebug war eine Firefox-Erweiterung für Developer-Tools.
Und vieles von den Überresten ist heute immer noch in Firefox.
Und ich denke mal, deswegen hat Firefox nach wie vor auch noch die besten Developer-Tools.
Gibi ist ein jQuery-Klon, habe ich ja nie was von gehört.
Eine DevTools.
Das größte, was man zu Browser-DevTools bekommt, ist, die Source in Notepad zu sehen.
Das ist großartig.
Und dieser Typ, Joe Hewitt, hat an Mozilla gearbeitet.
Er ist einer der Founding-Engineer für Firefox.
Aber dann ging er weg und fing an, Web-Applikationen zu bauen.
Und er hat realisiert, dass es eine große Schmerz war, weil er nichts debugieren konnte.
Also hat er einen Browser-Plugin gegründet, den Firebug.
Und ich kann es euch zeigen.
Hier habe ich Firefox und habe den Plugin installiert.
Wenn ich auf den Klick rechts klicke, kann ich das Element inspektieren und ihr seht viele Sachen, die da sind, die da sind.
Wir haben eine Konsole, HTML-View, wir können den CSS sehen, wir haben einen Script-Debugger.
So sehen die Developer-Tools heute immer noch aus. Und warum?
Weil irgendein Typ auf die Idee gekommen ist, wir machen eine Firefox-Erweiterung.
Und wisst ihr, ich rate das jetzt einfach mal.
Und wisst ihr, was ich glaube?
Dass in der heutigen Zeit mit dem heutigen Firefox so ein Plugin gar nicht mehr möglich gewesen wäre.
Weil die Firefox API auch immer weiter beschnitten wurde in den letzten Jahren.
Also ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass du quasi das, was damals quasi die Erfindung der DevTools war,
heute gar nicht mehr als Plugin überhaupt machen könntest.
Deswegen fand ich es auch ein bisschen blöd, dass Firefox das immer weiter beschnitten hat.
Ich frag mich schon seit Jahren, was denkt dann eigentlich Firefox?
Wer sind denn die Anwender von Firefox?
Die Oma um die Ecke?
Der nur nach 15 Casual Boon, der außer Chrome und Safari nichts kennt, was vorinstalliert ist?
Also ich bin der festen Überzeugung,
Firefox hat sich blöderweise immer weiter von ihren Core-Anwendern wegentwickelt die letzten Jahre über.
Trotzdem bin ich froh, dass es Firefox gibt.
Damals hat noch keiner, wie es Code Extensions gedacht, Leute.
Das ist übrigens, wahrscheinlich hat es auch kaum einer gesehen, das ist Chrome 1.0.
Wow, WAP?
Leute, WAP war das damals?
Übrigens, nochmal jetzt an der Stelle zum Beweis.
Es gibt doch diese Theorie, dass man, dass jeder, jeden Menschen auf der Welt über maximal, glaube ich, sechs oder sieben Ecken kennt.
Weiß jetzt nicht, wie man das nennt.
Aber ich kenne auch Steve Jobs.
Über zwei Ecken.
So ein Konsultentyp, der bei uns auf der Arbeit ist, der da irgendwas konsultet.
Der war 2008 auf der Präsentation, wo Steve Jobs das iPhone vorgestellt hat.
Also, Theorie wieder bestätigt.
Weird Flex, das war kein Flex.
Hat sich das wie nur ein Flex angeschaut.
Ja.
Das war immer noch eines der besten und gleichzeitig blödesten Ideen, was man machen konnte.
Node.js.
Na ja, Node ist bis heute nicht multithreaded.
Oder was heißt nicht multithreaded? Du kannst kein Multithreading in Node machen.
Ich glaube, du kannst mittlerweile Webworker-Shit und sowas in Node machen.
Aber richtiges Multithreading ist in JavaScript nicht.
Zumindest mit V8 JavaScript nicht.
Ist Node.js eine gute Technologie?
Muss man ganz klar sagen, ja ist es.
Es ist nicht umsonst millionenfach adoptet worden.
Man kann sich immer darüber lustig machen, was will man mit JavaScript auf dem Server, was soll man, warum Backends in Node.js.
Aber ja, es hat schon seinen Sinn.
Man kann natürlich sagen, es wurden nicht immer die besten Technologien auch adoptet.
Aber es hat schon seinen Sinn gehabt.
Gerade, dass die ganzen Frontend-Leute jetzt auf einmal easy irgendwelche Desktop-Anwendungen machen können mit Electron.
Oder irgendwelche AP-Backends machen können.
Das ging vorher nicht.
Und in gewisser Weise, Node hatte tatsächlich was Cooles.
Ich glaube, jetzt weiß ich auch, was er sagen möchte.
Das ist kein Multithreading.
Node hatte halt Multi-, wie nennt man das?
Multi-, Multi-, es ist auch nicht Multi-Processing, wie nennt man das?
Multi-, Multi-, Ausführung?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Weil wirklich Multithreaded, Asynchron, ja genau.
Also wirklich Multithreaded ist es ja nicht.
Du hast nicht mehrere Threads.
Du hast einen Thread, der alles ausführt.
Aber Konkurrent ist es, genau.
Aber wenn der nichts macht oder auf I.O. wartet oder so was,
dann kann der quasi asynchronen Bett gemacht, sich schlafen legen.
Und das führt was anderes aus und dann springt es wieder zurück rein.
Also ein bisschen so, wie das Async Await in.NET macht,
nur das Async Await in.NET auch gleichzeitig komplett Multithreaded sein kann.
Also dieses Reinspringen.
.NET hat standardmäßig nichts Eventloop-mäßiges oder so.
Aber die haben sich das ja von.NET abgeguckt aus JavaScript
mit ihrer Async Await-Geschichte.
Ja, aber das hat schon seinen Sinn gehabt.
Es war eine gute und gleichzeitig blöde Idee mit Node.js.
JavaScript.
Leute, ich glaube, wir wären noch nicht fertig.
Den Abschnitt gucken wir noch.
Das war überlegen.
Okay, Rails, Jackberry, Handlebars, okay.
Handlebars.
Ist Handlebars nicht diese komische Template,
JavaScript-Template-Engine?
So mit den Curly Braces und so was?
Handlebars?
So, dann gab es AngularJS, Ember, Backbone, Knockout.
Okay, ehrlich gesagt, das Einzige,
was ich davon mal hobbymäßig ein bisschen zum Basteln verwendet habe,
war tatsächlich Ember.
Und das hat mich so abgeschreckt von Frontend Frameworks,
weil es einfach so unnötig aufgeblasen und kompliziert
und man hat eigentlich gar nicht verstanden,
was es macht war, dass ich da keinen Bock hatte.
Richtig bloated.
Knockout habe ich mir mal ganz kurz angeguckt,
aber nie was mitgemacht.
Ansonsten, meine zwei Lieblings Frameworks aktuell sind
eindeutig Vue und Svelte und eigentlich hauptsächlich Svelte.
Und wisst ihr, warum Svelte?
Wisst ihr, wie es dazu gekommen ist?
Durch den Chat.
Hätte man nicht den Chat damals vorgeschlagen,
lasst doch mal Svelte angucken,
ich würde es wahrscheinlich nie angeguckt.
Massive.
High-Intelligenz-Quotient-Chat.
Big Brain.
Das ist die Mode schon wieder weg, oder wie?
Lustig.
Letztens war es noch da.
Der Handytipp ist ja schon wieder da.
AngularJS 1.8.
Also, ich habe von vielen Angular-Fans gehört,
so auch die letzten Jahre über,
dass sie das erste Angular am besten fanden.
Das erste AngularJS.
Und das AngularJS war POG,
und Angular ist bloated Mist.
Sagen nicht ich, habe ich von vielen schon gehört.
Wahrscheinlich ist es auch nicht so,
sondern so ein bisschen verklärte,
war alles so geil damals.
Aber wahrscheinlich war AngularJS noch irgendwie übersichtlich,
und AngularJS ist bloated AF.
Backbone.
Backbone gibt es heute immer noch.
Hat letztens erst wieder irgendwelche Updates bekommen.
Guck mal.
Backbone.js.
Nicht, dass ich mich da jetzt vertue.
Na ja, letztens erst wieder.
Aber...
Knockout hat sich nie so richtig durchgesetzt.
Das war eigentlich ganz cool.
Damals.
Boomer time.
Guck mal.
Wird nicht mehr.
Is it dead?
Okay, exellent.
Da gucken wir morgen weiter.
Wir sind bei 44 Minuten.
Ich lasse das mal so auf.
Passt.
Das wird heute nämlich nix mehr.
Was haben wir?
Interview mit einem FFmpeg-Enthusiast.
Ach, das ist der Typ da.
Das ist meistens nicht lustig.
Automatic Home Lab mit Ansible.
Gucken wir uns auch angucken das nächste Mal.
Firebase.
Gucken wir uns auch an.
Gucken wir, wenn ihr klar was Gescheites.
Battlefield Engine Upgraded.
Was wollen sie da upgraden?
Guck mal.
Das wollte mir nicht ernsthaft erzählen,
dass die Leute haben, die die Frostbite Engine sinnvoll upgraden können,
wenn die nicht mal mehr Leute haben,
die was anderes als Kisten auf der Map platzieren können.
Gut.
Mir ist auch klar, dass das unterschiedliche Leute sind.
Aber die hatten so viele Probleme in der Entwicklung,
weil sie niemand mehr hatten,
der mit Frostbite was anfangen kann.
Was wollen sie da großartig weiterentwickeln?
Kriegen sie es nicht geschissen?
Kriegen sie es?
Oh, ich kriege meine eigenen Videos empfohlen, Pog.
Okay, Leute.
Ich muss jetzt ins Bett.
Visual Studio Code Extensions gucke ich mir auch immer gerne an.
Vielleicht was Neues dabei.
Moin.
Alles klar.
So.
Chat, Bettgetime.
Wollt ihr Outro-Musik haben oder nicht?
Ihr könnt es euch nicht aussuchen.
Hast du die neue Suche im Archiv gesehen?
Ne.
Archiv.
Punkt.
Nein, das ist nicht Archiv.
Altyz.
Es ist jetzt ein bisschen schneller, oder?
Nee, das nicht.
Wie ist denn dieезд alle Art von 보니까.
Azure.
zusammen oder einfach nur def einfach nur def ok ok neue suche stream ui ui ui aiaiaiai
mit placeholder images auch noch pog guckt euch das mal an lazy loading placeholder
images jetzt jetzt gehts aber rund hier so was von responsive was denn das
hast du ist das schon trends transcripted oder was hast du das auch schon gemacht
das ist nice leute ihr habt vielleicht gar mitgekriegt aber wir haben uns eine
oder was heißt wir der serious max ich sag jetzt mal wir ich hatte minimal auch was damit zu tun
wir haben uns eine vm gemietet in der cloud mit einer 3090 gtx und die macht jetzt grafikkarten
machine learning encoded transcript von meinem video also die lädt das video file und entstellt
einen script über das was ich sage im video weiß gar nicht ob man sich das transcript
irgendwie anzeigen lassen kann kann man sich anzeigen lassen untertitel hier untertitel
tld list.com noch nicht ok aber das ist das ist wirklich das ist das ist sehr nice ja das ist
das ist wirklich richtig richtig nice jetzt kann man nämlich auch das archiv durchsuchen
jetzt kann man das archiv durchsuchen nach zb keck das sage ich öfters na gut was soll
ich mal suchen ja publics gremple gremple guck und jetzt findet er das im transcript findet
er guck mal der findet jetzt der man kann quasi das was ich im video sage jetzt volltext
durchsuchen das ist richtig richtig nice wie machst du die volltext suche hast du das
mit der mit der mit der postgres geschichte gemacht die ich geschrieben habe oder nimmst
was anderes postgres also nimmst du die postgres volltextsuche oder wobei das können wir ganz
einfach testen aber die volltextsuche nimmt null gremple stopp es ist die postgres volltextsuche
wäre es die volltextsuche mit 3 grem index support dann wäre die datenbank jetzt deutlich
größer aber man könnte zum beispiel nach pell suchen er wird trotzdem finden aber in
dem fall ist ja auch sinnvoll nach wörtern zu suchen i3 findet er nix ich glaube mal i3 hat
das das transcript zeug nicht findet gibt es nix ich glaube man muss in der suche mehr
als drei buchstaben eingeben guck mal stats alter das hat das aber übertrieben hier guckt
euch das mal an vor allem guckt mal wie stylisch wie stylisch das schon leht hier alles was
ist das ist das craft gs oder was ist da way to dank
mehr stunden gestreamt als letzten monat gesprochene wörter insgesamt ok ich habe also seit ich
angefangen habe zu streamen nee in den nur in den indizierten videos habe ich sehe ich
das richtig neun fast zehn millionen wörter gesprochen alter ist das viel und nur 67.000
einzigartige wörter gar nicht mal so schlecht oder durchschnittliche wörter pro stream die
statistik ist wirklich nice
die mod stats gibt es doch gibt es doch komm doch jetzt doch gleich top klipper der sebarro
was sonst ja und ich selber ach ja ich weiß warum ich hab was hab ich clips gemacht ich
weiß nur was ich clips gemacht habe für videos wenn ich wenn ich manche ausschnitte in videos
rein machen wollte twitch emotes better twitch tv emotes ffz emotes wurst wupp wurst sehr
nice und wisst ihr was was noch viel geiler ist es gibt sogar darkseam und das sieht gescheit
aus hast du die farben dir selbst ausgedacht oder ist das ist das irgendwie in den ist
das ist das tailwind oder ist das irgendwas fertig ist oder was was was ist da unten drunter
css technisch bootstrap customized ok ja richtig richtig muss man dazu ja sage ich massive
pock das andere ist das andere ist ein custom custom thema ja beste bestes müssen wir so
lassen solis für die heckermans aber das ist eh das beste steam dafür ja ja ja ja
das ist wirklich das ist wirklich richtig gut geworden muss man mal sagen kann man
so können wir sogar master die agile github progas auger ja das ist das ist die einzig
die einzig wahre github gruppe in die man rein muss viele progas progas giga chat progas
kann hier wer französisch nehmen egal leute ich kann jetzt aber ins bett gehen wir sehen
uns bis denn macht's gut zu